des cimetières connectés en vous
baladant dans le cimetière de
jouars-pontchartrain vous pourrez voir
d'étranges petits carrés pixelisé sur
les tombes depuis le 12 décembre quatre
pierres tombales du cimetière sont ornés
de qrcode une fois flasher avec un
téléphone il redirige vers une interface
où la famille du défunt peut stocker
jusqu'à 2 giga octet de vidéos images ou
texte il suffit de flasher le qr code et
à partir de là vous arrivez sur notre
solution qui n'est pas une application à
télécharger mais un site internet donc
en fait ça fonctionne sur tous les
téléphones et donc le qr code est donc
pas se poser positionner là sur le côté
gauche je vais tout simplement le
scanner
on trouvera des des photos des images
alors les premières images concerne les
oeuvres d'art que l'on trouve dans la
chapelle de l'hôpital et là vous avez
accès à toute l'histoire les trois
siècles d'histoire de ses soeurs au
centre hospitalier qui est devenu le
centre hospitalier de la mode l'objectif
raconter l'histoire du défunt on va
pouvoir rappeler la voix de la personne
son image des anecdotes de sa vie sa vie
tout court feuilleter ensemble l'album
de famille surtout été pensée pour les
familles ou pour l'histoire en donnant
une vraie trace des personnes qui sont
enterrés à différents endroits le caveau
des soeurs de la charité et la tombe de
jean stanislas barrier ancien maire de
la commune sont les premiers à
bénéficier de ce dispositif
les qr codes sont proposés par
l'entreprise yvelinoise de gea ci en
partenariat avec l'association jouars
pontchartrain et l'histoire ça peut
s'adresser à un usage intime celui de la
famille ou des eaux des amis et
également ce qui a intéressé
l'association je reprends ce retrait une
histoire c'était de pouvoir raconter
l'histoire de la commune au travers des
gens illustres des gens remarquables qui
sont dans ce cimetière pour les
historiens c'est extraordinaire parce
qu'on a vraiment envie de raconter les
histoires et à moins de l'écrire dans un
lit
on fait toujours des coupures ont fait
toujours un mois de ce pas dans un
journal municipal ou autre on ne raconte
pas la vie des gens célèbres donc toute
cette mémoire enfouie disparaît là on la
fait revivre de quoi dérouter
l'expression muet comme une tombe pour
la somme de 97 euros vous pouvez vous
aussi faire vivre la mémoire d'un défunt
en contactant la société via le site oct
us vitesse